los estruendos persisten en mac mood la
defensa de las tropas ucranianas
continúan esta localidad de toniesk el
principal objetivo actual de Rusia y que
Los mercenarios del grupo Wagner dijeron
que se tomarán entre marzo y abril lo
que podría recrudecer los combates en la
semana siguientes
en una escalada de una 10 la situación
en un 5 en este momento tenemos que
reconocer los éxitos del enemigo las
divisiones regulares rusas trabajan aquí
Tienen grupos de artillería regulares y
disparan con precisión hagamos lo que
hagamos ellos responden
según el Instituto para el estudio de la
guerra Rusia sigue logrando avances en
las inmediaciones de batmut y lo está
rodeando paulatinamente antes de lanzar
una ofensiva mayor los soldados
ucranianos mantienen la confianza para
poder repeler a las tropas invasoras
pero remarcan la necesidad de contar con
mayor armamento de occidente
dennos más equipo militar más armas nos
encargaremos del ocupante ruso los
destruiremos juntos a la victoria
Ucrania está unida y entera Gloria
Ucrania Gloria a los héroes
este viernes luego de que fallecieran
cinco civiles por los ataques en las
últimas horas la vicepresivo primera
ministra de Ucrania y Dina berechuc
Cristóbal alrededor de 6000 habitantes
abandonar la pequeña localidad la toma
de allanaría el camino a Rusia
sacramators y eslobians las ciudades más
importantes que controlan la región y
marcaría su primera Gran Victoria tras
varios meses de reveses militares en el
frente